Okay, today I'm going to show you how to let yourself go.
I hope you like it.
And if you don't, I don't care.
The first step to letting yourself go...
...is finding a comfortable pair of sweatpants with an elastic waistband.
You may want to skip washing them too.
The more stains and cat hair, the better.
Red lipstick always makes a statement...
...like this one.
If you really want to turn heads, you can use this new fragrance from France.
Me? I just use fresh laundry.
If you're too lazy to get the remote, I recommend fashioning a long poking device like this one.
Oh, and I'm just obsessed with this new volumizing hair dryer I just bought.
I just can't even...
Now the trick to getting the perfect bedhead look is to basically not get out of bed.
I think I'm just gonna take a nap.
If you'd like more makeup tips, you can visit my blog at stopbotheringme.net/whatever.